all the locals in our in our area code
have been getting uh been getting robbed
for cali converters um they've been
coming in probably about
eight to nine jobs per week three to
five on a normal day and anywhere from
five to ten on a busy day we're ranging
anywhere from a thousand to three
thousand sometimes four thousand
depending if it's a dual sick cat system
so just be very aware and just know your
surroundings priuses are the worst uh we
have done one prius job three times
three times with all oem parts and it
it's it's unbelievable like just the
fact that you know their insurance paid
out they got the car fixed you know even
with the theft deterrent device on there
one of the cat shields they still cut
through it they still took the stuff and
it happened three times total i i get
stories from people that come in here
all the time and in all reality it's not
worth
your life or you going to prison over a
park being stolen from your car yeah
it's unfortunate but you want to go to
prison because you just shot somebody
for stealing a cat that was worth a few
hundred bucks like you know if they
already got it and you have insurance
let it go you know just be the bigger
person let it go and move on with your
life you know it's not worth ruining
your life over one part being stolen